they walk through the factory gates to
start a shift before going out onto the
floor they put on made-to-measure shoes
the other foods we've got a special
insole the cushioning that the new shoes
have is continually being developed so
your stance is better some work stations
are always on your feet so you need good
shoes do you know the more mature will
you should equal the safety shoes are
made to suit his weight it's something
new for Reinhold apfel who's been
working at the plant for 25 years the
assembly facility is only a few years
old it was already clear to BWW that
staff was aging back then
rear axle drive units are assembled at
plant 2.1 in dingle fing BMW sites of
varying size are supplied from here yet
even though the workers are aging the
quality and performance should remain
the same weinhold apfel for example is
48 a few things have changed the floor
is one of them we're not standing on
hard concrete anymore it's all been made
much softer a wood floor has been laid
where he works the workstations are also
being designed with ergonomic sin mind
what's easier you don't have to bend
down so far anymore and you don't have
to reach so far either the work feels
more comfortable with the mall Biden
taking a break to stretch has become a
must for Reinhold Apfel the balance
exercises that have been specially
developed for each station really helped
yes he and many others are less likely
to be found in the fitness and quiet
room physiotherapist Daniella aunt makes
regular visits she knows the problem is
that me free in this off tomorrow it's
not optimal for everyone in terms of the
exercises not everyone wants to do them
they're a bit bashful about stretching
and bending while others are looking on
well I'm gonna die back souchong
Reinhold apfel prefers to visit her
alone as well he'd rather go and have a
bite to eat during a break then go work
out but the demographically correct
ideas have arrived at the cafeteria as
well there's a point system and green
means healthy ones i drool you check out
the green dots but you usually go with
what you're hungry for the model how to
get the with in doing this greenie roast
pork seems the most popular and that's
reinholds choice
during a single shift the workers also
change stations to prevent their body
being worked exclusively from one
direction
reinhold oakville prefers to sis while
he works that's why the first thing he
does is reset the height of the shelves
and the chair he uses at this station is
especially overhauled hairdressers do
the plants director hines pune is
heading for the planning office the
assembly facility costs 20 million euros
including the ergonomic alterations of
workstations now the rest of the plant
is gradually being refitted to suit an
aging workforce hamada meet the baby we
ask the workers what caused the greatest
amount of physical strain at their
workstation hines Bruner is a trained
manager he says he's sure the effort is
worth it there's no way this is a neat
move it's not just for the employees
which is important of course it's really
for all of us in the meet the weather
lately if a worker can do the job more
easily than the quality improves and so
does performance so it's a win-win
situation and win-win is the place we
want to get to when this came out the
poopin tomorrow the idea seems to be
working for the most part but does
Reinhold Apfel want to work into his old
age no no when it's time it's time you
shouldn't overdo it I'd like to enjoy my
later years a bit too can you leave me
some Donegan easy if things stay as they
are the last time Reinhold Apfel goes
through this case he would be 67 but
that's almost 20 years away
you